henry bari giorgia gazzetti ragazzi
benvenuti questo video sono un fan di j
e che sono qua con suriano infortunato
in questo momento today siamo qua per
fare una sottospecie di sfida di disegno
così vogliamo chiamarle sfida a apple
uno solo è una sfida divisa fine niente
storia questa tavola grafi tavoletta
grafica auletta graval e della grafica
che praticamente permette di fare i
disegni belli grossi abbiamo segnato
quattro personaggi famosi che ci
confronteremo su quello quindi vediamo
se riusciamo a fare meglio il disegno
uno rispetto all'altro bene
partiamo col primo personaggio famoso di
giudei che con il sisley ariana grande
allora il primo problema è che una
grande e troppo [ __ ] quindi non
riuscirei mai a cosa rara purifica me
bassa iniziato perché ovviamente saranno
tavoli allora di casa acer subito
qualcosa nella mia vita mio addio state
per assistere all'opera della vita
facciamo la mettiamo un'altra
io non ho parole aggiungiamo un'altra
cosa questa sfida
cioè non puoi premere mai contro z mai
contro 0 e va bene ariana grande anche
detta riana grossa arianna grossa e dove
trovarla al cinema secco il vecchio ma
non riesco a farlo a alla z che agli
occhi gli occhi saranno perfette
i ritardi che faccio di solito sembrano
quasi veri a questo veterano detto che
non era non c'e la sfida da questo punto
di vista il cast so se mi compare una
grande striscia la bella testa con il
codice a barre ma ora come sensuale
mamma mara che aveva garantito sulle
stagionali che fa così
vedi il dito sensuale che se lo tocca
fantastico dai ho visto di peggio
e non è cosa si sveglia la mattina e
peggio e di c è si la gamba un po cross
di seedorf e haryana e completa manca un
po il piedino porca [ __ ] iscriviti
direi che siamo apposto dover petalo che
sarà una mare
allora io io direi che secondo me
l'impegno c'è anche la gente non
apprezza l'arte non la presero porca
[ __ ]
cos'è sta roba jack sparrow noi facciamo
il cerchietto ha provato seabra c'è un
pochettino te la cavi del settore era al
mondo è poi qui a uno sguardo che prima
possono accompagnare meno male che ci
sei tu ti rimetti quel tocco di sensuale
che venivano perfetto patito e tre volte
la sua bocca ma gli occhi sei sicuro che
questa è la manovella poi che è un po
monca prova anche qui c'è un po di
braccino che tranne lettieri chiesa
braccino salvarci genovese lei
ragazzi io non ho parole veramente si
aspetta guarda le mezze pippe mettertelo
meglio a favore di camera va e 321
spiega e shelley trasformata in fiona di
shrek è vero il problema allora voi non
visita dai ragazzi della tattica c'è
sarà un messo descrivete dei commenti
primo round chi secondo voi ha vinto
strame pensarà primo round secondo run
the alzando e portando descrivere i nomi
di chi ha vinto ogni esame sarà tutto
prima ii 84 sordi sul riso riso
ribadiamo il secondo nel secondo end
secondo ali jasper le idee
justin bieber
la squadra ha capito solo dopo cosa
volevi fare allora non importa justin
bieber ragazze justin bieber isabella
volta inizi tu una mano che per cui se
hai dato a g perfetto sicuramente li ha
fatti con la stessa cura
mi stai facendo tu poi qua ai capelli
lui c'è un po il taglio capito che c'e
la stempiatura qui c'è un po che sembra
tagliato male tagliato e qua poi ci hai
subito i suoi tuffi che faccetta nera
poi annuncia un po di sopracciglia da
stronzo vedi però non scavano
sopracciglia da stronzi con che sguardo
signori
beh dai io vedo solo perché dopo non
riuscivo a fare mai questa poi li
facciamo la collana è bellissimo perché
sembra che gli siano cresciuti gli
spaghetti sulla testa e piatta la testa
6 esempio next one ragazzi proprio la
partenza signori c'è questo non può
essere il collo però in questo è
maurizio costanzo perché io li faccio
tutti i più grossi di quello che sono
vi sembra quasi morto dentro è
bellissimo qual è stata la prima gara
quali dai va bene ci provo
se dopo di che i calciatori tipo
dell'uganda che ci hanno visto degli
spike la mano potrebbe essere un
problema perché ha visto l'ho fatto
molto bene la mano non so testo come
riuscirò a picco ci siamo seri e
prudenti
siamo ritornati in voga [ __ ] vado il
papà del padre da yo e non è così ma ho
visto del peggio a dare i signori io non
so io io io ho preso parte va là che è
sempre stata la nave va apprezzato
questa cosa ti suggerisce quest'opera
suicidio vomito qual è il tuo preferito
decidono ai ragazzi
direi di passare alla prossima per ora
abbiamo dato il meglio di noi anche qua
porto io
allora ragazzi la prossima devo
iniziarla io per forza di cose perché è
una cosa che mi viene dal cuore
infatti è la mamma di fa vj hem aghano
selena che che stai guardando questo
video alla faccia turbata dalle serie a
mio dio così mi sta insegnando fa vj
adesso diventano più bella di contro
sono già e una suora avevo selena con
farmi scherzi eh beh questa è dai la
società e la città noi svetta aspettano
ma chi e gérard depardieu e gérard
depardieu la del naso a patata c caso è
quello di de bardi e ragazzi a vedere il
naso avanti e se la tangenziale che va
amata in tutto e per tutto ma non è una
donna questa è una donna non insultare
la mia salerno poi una non è male questa
è la bambola gonfiabile è una zappa e il
figlio distaccata selena ma mi ama mi e
dopo questo video ma cosa vuoi di più
santo iddio mancava giusto da ciò che le
scendeva fin qua bellissima ragazzi io
pago io direi che questo io faccio io
però non il pittore provoca e selena
versione minecraft lei al è fatta kubica
beh cioè in occhio è visto di esatto la
sorella di lei da bocca tipo ma voglio
che non fa ma sta roba è impossibile o
no
boccia sembra il die o pensavo peggio
pensavo molto bene di cm in su sembra
quasi una persona sembra un secolo si
deve essere un must have e sebbene
sarebbe un traguardo confrontiamo
affrontiamo perse un po dificio
consultarle questo perché una sembra la
versione incazzata dell'altro allora
ragazzi quale il prossimo l'ultimo come
vi abbiamo detto prima è speciale nel
senso dobbiamo riuscire a farlo io
proverò a fare follie pur di provare a
fare me fa vigenti hai capito che senza
foto devi guardarmi in faccia
ok alla fai così abbassa il cappellino
più possibile così migliacco cinismo il
cappellino e una sforzo più facile di
esatto ma io non guardo neanche ora
diritto il parrocchie di quasi fiducioso
delle mie abilità incredibili ragazzi
adesso capisco cosa provano i gli
artisti di strada che provano a fare un
ritratto tivano l'esperimento sociale
facciamo gli artisti di strada la sua
volta caricato importabile e facciamo
disegnare pareggio una mera vengono una
merda alla fine e liti non se
l'aspettano perché ti ho fatto un pene
al posto del naso
ho sbagliato non avendo di 600 di
ritratti così lunghi bene finito ad
altre altre ti giri ti guardi ma è un
due tre questo è un barbone e cioè il
governo è veramente di lei sbornia gli
amx venuto bene la scritta la stessa
io pensavo che io che i miei mesi fatto
più danni invece no dai
secondo me c'è oltre a te caro vai mai
aiutato
ovviamente neanche tu devi sbirciare non
ha il cappello è venuto bene non
guardare mai perché avrei dovuto bene
non voglio vedere non vuoi vedere
diverso come o non vuoi negati 20 da
solo il cappello fa troppo ridere sulla
concentrazione
ok poi qua c'è simboli di giapponesi
aspetta
allora secondo me ci può stare
mi giro aspetta che non si vede bene
inquadratura puoi andare 3 3 addio già
fu minchia bene solo stessi compiuto
come i simboli sono belli ma allora va
da cappellino è fatto come ho potuto se
lo più per il marito ricco lo so però è
veramente il ferry dormitorio lato è
bellissimo il cappello e invece la
faccia pericolo sai come uccide mi ha
vinto lo sporco ragazzi a voi comunque
round 1 round 2 run 342 punti con il
vincitore schwirz lo voglio mettere gli
ha ridato sappiamo bene io niente dire
che possiamo concludere che questa
sessione incredibile di disegno
ringraziarvi per avermi dato delle
lezioni di disegno che mi servirà per
quanto per il futuro per fare il
ritratto alla mia prossima ragazza va
bene va bene per chiudere il vino
ragazzi spero che questo video di aver
scelto come sensi mio vissuto sul
momento è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come invito a totana
descrizione fisica e denis ci vediamo il
prossimo video col telecomando del
condizionatore by suri ieri non ti ho
fatto cadere
beh ragazzi